do you know how many possible most white
has for the starting of the position
if your answer is 20 you are right I'm
Kathy and in this video I'm gonna show
you every first move ranked from the
worst to the best let's break it down we
do have eight pawns each of these pawns
can make one or two moves in total 16
moves besides that we have two knights
and those Knights can make four moves
that's how we got 20 first moves guys it
is very important to choose right
opening and the correct first moves for
that we have some of the basic rules in
chess let me show that this is the
center of the board we would like to
control the center so our first rule is
to control the center by the Pawns
second rule is to develop the minor
pieces towards the center and the third
rule is to keep the king safe for that
you need to Castle short side or long
side that sounds so easy and so simple
right let's now put this into the
practice we have categorized all these
20 moves in our first category is never
never do this and the move F3 well you
can make this move if you want to
demonstrate the shortest Checkmate in
chess after E5 you can make G4 a
horrible move Queen H4 is a Checkmate
other than that F3 is not the move that
I would like to recommend to you because
it weakens the king and it's not worth
it to play another move which fits this
category is A4
it is really far from the center and
perhaps the idea is to develop the work
on the second move black goes against
that plays D5 and after Rook A3 captures
this rook and wins the game so it's not
worthy how about if we try on the other
side of the board with H4 the same thing
can happen Rook H3 Bishop H3 thank you
very much this is very bad start of a
game how about if we play a little bit
safe H3 this move can be very useful in
some of the positions to avoid Bishop G4
or Knight F6 Knight G4 but this is just
start of the game we don't really need
to play such a passive moves our next
category is when the knights are making
a wrong turn Knight A3 and Knight H3
those moves are developing moves but not
the Right Moves we would like to develop
the knights towards the center not at
the edge of the board because those
Knights at the edge of the boards are
very limited Knight D3 is called a
sodium attack
n and a are standing for a chemical
terms it is known that if you're using
too much of the sodium your blood
pressure goes up night day 3 also has
the same effect so it is not recommended
to play too much of this move how about
Knight H3 this opening is called almond
opening and has been played by many
Green Masters including Magnus Carlsen
he has played this move in 2008 against
drev he has won this game but he has
never played ever since so it can be a
hint for us the idea of the move is to
play F3 Knight F2 develop the light
Square Bishop castleland to continue to
play on the king side or you can play G3
fiance of the bishop Castle bring the
Knight on F4 that's possible you can
give a try if you really wanted to play
with black pieces but they gave you
white pieces then this is for you and
our next category is a pass move and
this is A3 so basically just pass the
turn to black to choose the opening this
move is very popular and has been played
by Hikaru Nakamura Magnus Carlson Daniel
dubov and many more it's quite
interesting the name of this opening is
Anderson's opening because it has been
played by Adolf Anderson against Paul
Murphy and he won with one A3 our next
category is mouse lips and those moves
are E3 D3 and C3 a bit far from the
center and quite passive Moves In fact
E3 has the most difficult name I'm gonna
give a try to say it out of loud it is
called one at Chris if we have someone
who's fixed that please correct me if
I'm wrong or let me know if I'm anywhere
close so the idea of this move is to get
the center later on maybe D4 maybe C4
maybe would like to build up the
Stonewall with F4 D4 and C3 so basically
you're not really closing here the light
Square Bishop you are not avoiding
Knight F3 next move and it is playable
but a little bit another move is D3 the
same idea you're not fighting for the
center but later on you can play C4 you
can play E4 you can also get Knight here
fiancato bishop and play king's attack
color reversed in fact this move has
been played by a former world champion
Gary Kasparov against deep blue in the
game three karika Sparrow decided not to
go to the main lines and confuse the
artificial intelligence with 1d3 it
really worked out and the game has been
ended in a draw in 48 moves our next
movie this category is C3
well this is named Zaragoza opening and
it is a kind of waiting move so let's
say black plays D5 or Knight F6 you can
play D4 and next Bishop F4 E3 and this
is London system some of you might like
it very much and would like to play so
go ahead and try it if you're opponent
plays C5 and you go E4 here to control
the center this is the Sicilian Defense
with C3 it is called elephant variation
very sharp white is trying to get the
center next move with D4 and it is
totally playable moving forwards to the
next category and this is the category
maybe don't and the move one G4
this move is also in the edge of the
board not fighting for the center but it
is very tricky black usually responds
with D5 after Bishop G2 white is
sacrifice in a pawn if black takes this
Pawn white goes with C4 it creates a lot
of Danger on the diagonal also Queen
gets on B3 to annoy the opponent B7 it
is really really sharp however G4 is not
fighting for the center as I mentioned
black and simply just developed the
pieces for instance C6 here to go
against the light Square Bishop black is
the one who controls the center white is
the one who controls the king side but
it is maybe too early to control the
king side blackened later on just
respond with H5 to annoy the white Pawn
now moving to next move and this is the
move I'm sure many of you like to see F4
called birth opening if you are a player
who likes sharp positions who likes to
attack the opponent's king go for it f4
on the other hand is a bit dangerous
because you are also weakening your king
you need to be very careful with that
you can play Knight F3 then develop the
light Square Bishop castle and your Pawn
is already on F4 be ready to be pushed
all the way to F5 and F6 to attack the
king well you can try going to the next
moves Knight to C3 this is a sound move
but it's not so great as the other move
that I'm going to show you the idea of
the Knight C3 is to control the center
with a knight and also to develop the
Knight black usually responds here with
D5 or Knight F6 so let's see what
happens after D5 you can play D4 and
Bishop to F4 and it transposes to jobava
London which is very popular these days
it has a sharp character and it's
possible to play now we're going to take
a look if b-pawn goes forward B4 or B3
B4 has two names it is Polish opening or
orangutan opening the idea of this move
is to develop the dark Square Bishop
into attack on G7 it is very sharp also
controls the C5 square and it has its
own ideas I think it is totally worth
the try on the other hand B3 is more
peaceful the idea is the same to play
Bishop to B2 to attack DG 7 Pawn in the
long term 2 attack on the king side
these days it is very popular to play
1v3 in The Blitz Games because it has a
sharp character there's a lot of tactics
there and also it avoids the main
theoretical lines now we are moving to
the category where we have selected all
the good moves starting with one G3 the
idea of this move is to develop the king
side first keep this King at the safety
and then to fight for the center let me
put some of the moves on the board we
have now castled our King is safe we
fight for the center and here we have a
setup of Catalan defense which is very
popular nowadays and it has quite sharp
character another very popular move is
one C4 known as English opening white is
controlling D5 square and wants to play
Knight C3 next move
well black usually responds with E5 and
here we have this setup where white can
choose to play in the center with D4 or
after developing the king side to play
F4 and to go after the king or to play
Rook to B1 and before to play on the
queen side so this opening is very
flexible and you can choose the plan on
the board and the last move in this
category is Knight F3 known as ratty
opening it's also one of my favorite
openings because it really goes well to
my name Kathy Andretti and I like to
play it for some reason well for me this
is a backup opening because I am a D4
player and if you're a D4 player then
you are comfortable to play Knight F3 as
well it is very flexible you can play
here D4 as I usually do you can play C4
you can play G3 you can play B3 you can
play E3 it is really really flexible so
you can actually try to play this move
as well and here we are in the final
category where we have the best moves
one E4 which says I'm the best and one
D4 which says no I'm the best the most
common question in chess is E4 or D4
here we are to answer this question well
they are both equally strong because
they are attacking the center right away
another common thing between these two
moves is that you need to know a lot of
theory if you play 24 or 1d4 let's go
with D4
this move is the most played among the
chess players according to the database
kingspawn is really good opening for the
beginners because it gives you a lot of
possibilities for traps and it is a good
tool to attack your opponent's king
let's say the possible openings from
black side you should be ready for one
E5 or to C5 this is a Sicilian Defense
also it's quite popular to see move C6
karkan defense there is another move E6
French defense
Knight F6 is also possibility or Knight
to C6 or there's also way to respond
with D6 or G6 or B6 a lot of theory
let's now go to D4 this is more solid
setup and it offers you a positional
struggles after D4 now black can respond
with D5 this is the most common move and
Knight to F6 to control the center
there are moves like C5 to challenge the
center right away or E5 with the same
idea there are waiting moves too like D6
C6 or E6 also G6 the one of the sharpest
line is to play F5 which is called touch
defense that's it guys for today I hope
you like this video please make sure you
like the channel and press the Bell
button to see the similar content I'm
woman Grandmaster katita salosh really
and I'll see you in the next video
good